great ideas we are great ideas our ideas
of solve a problem in a unique way
usually happen when two old ideas meet
together for the first time so great
ideas are not new ideas they are usually
a combination of existing ideas and
that's where brainstorming is powerful
because it brings together people with
different experiences so they can all
merge their ideas together so that's
where Design Thinking becomes effective
because it promotes that collaborative
approach bring people from different
parts of the organization together to
bring in their different knowledge and
there are different expertise and
provide their input into how you're
gonna solve a problem and by combining
those ingredients together you can come
up with new and creative ways to solve
the problem
one thing that we have learned over the
years is that that process doesn't work
with everyone so we have developed our
own variation that also can work well
with it reverse so we can ask people to
individually think about 10 or 15 ways
in which they can address the problem do
that ahead of time and then meet as a
group share their ideas and then engage
into a more structured brainstorm so a
combination of individual idea
generation and combined group idea
generation can work really well it's all
about putting yourself in your users
shoes spend time with your users ask
them questions think ahead what do you
want to learn and draft some interview
questions and then engage in a
conversation don't make it into an
interview and get in a conversation but
be prepared
what do you want to learn be a good
listener
try to listen to the stories that your
user is going to share with you ask them
about the last time they have faced a
challenging situation and how they
addressed that challenging situation
that's a way for you to learn about your
user if they are willing to let you
observe them while they go through their
everyday life that's a great way to get
deeper insights if you start discovering
what is the problem you want to solve
and they let you solve that problem for
them or work with them to solve that
problem that's a great way to really
understand what the problem is
when you observe them you see what they
actually go through but when you
actually do it that's when you can
really understand how difficult some
things may be or what are the emotions
that some challenges are creating I may
tell you that changing the tire of my
car is difficult but in order for you to
understand why it's difficult you could
probably want to do it yourself
or I may tell you that I find a
particular task challenging but you may
be able to better appreciate how
challenging it is when you try to do it
yourself you want something that you can
take back to your user and your user can
interact with it they can feel it they
can play with it they can use it one way
or another so the thing about quick and
inexpensive ways that you can make your
early idea usable so you can go back to
your user your customer and get feedback
and that feedback now is giving you the
information is this a good idea or is
this a bad idea oftentimes from your
users reaction you may discover that the
problem that you thought they had is not
there and they have a different problem
but you will also learn more about what
they want what their preferences are so
you're using this process of generating
ideas and taking about your user and
getting feedback as a way to refine your
understanding of the problem but also
refine your idea
in order for ideas to be valuable
the economics need to work if it's a new
product idea you need to build a viable
business model but your idea may involve
changing and eternal process within an
organization so you need to understand
whether the resources that you need to
bring together and what is the case that
you will need to make to other people to
convince them to change that process if
we are working on a new product idea the
first question is what is the value
proposition write down the value
proposition the second one is who is
going to be a customer your customer
segment define your customer segment
third one is how are you gonna reach
them and the fourth one is how are you
gonna make money now the business model
canvas has nine elements but I have
identified the first four that you need
to address now once you have this the
value proposition is something that you
test in your direct interaction of your
user with your prototype through their
reaction what is the value proposition
that they see does it match your value
proposition the customer segment once
you define your customer segment the
users that you talk to must belong in
the customer segment you have defined so
if I believe that my customer segments
are teenagers and I've taught you to my
colleagues at Stanford and sharing my
idea to my colleagues at Stanford there
is a misalignment if I'm targeting
teenagers the customers that I'm going
to be testing my product ID with needs
to be teenagers the third one is how are
you gonna reach them that's an
interesting one so if my assumption is
I'm gonna reach them at them at the mall
then try to go to the mall and find your
users there the first one pricing when
you troduce a prototype you can tell
them and when this becomes a food
product this is the price that we're
going to charge and people are going to
react so the fundamental idea is there
are four basic elements of the business
model that
need to prototype early value
proposition customer segments channel of
how you're gonna find the customer and
revenue how you're gonna make money make
sure that as you start prototyping and
testing your prototype you do that in a
way that is consistent with those
elements of the business model and
that's how you can product have a
business model there are some problems
that are not solvable you may not find
the technology that is kind of solve a
particular problem but what you want to
do is discover that quickly so the
methodology doesn't necessarily generate
better ideas than competing
methodologies if there are competing
methodologies is just that this
methodology allows you to test your
ideas quickly to see which was hold
promise creativity is not rocket science
creativity is a structure systematic way
to solve problems so the first thing
that I would like to tell to executives
and organizations if you are a
successful executive or organization you
are successful because you are a good
problem solver so if you are a good
problem solver you are creative creative
doesn't mean you're Van Gogh or Picasso
they are creative in their own
discipline you can be creative in your
own discipline so if you can solve
problems you can be creative
you